hello readers today i want to talk about
objective summaries by way of
introducing you to the character of joe
friday a fictional cop from an old radio
show from the 50s called dragnet the
show had this iconic theme and it went
like this
friday was a very straightforward almost
relentless character and the catchphrase
associated with his character was just
the facts all we want are the facts
ma'am was the sort of thing that he
would say
and that's what we're talking about
today just the facts there's this idea
called objectivity that you can talk
about something without inserting any
opinions which are personal thoughts or
beliefs
doing this being objective is very
difficult opinions want to creep in
so what does it mean for a summary to be
objective it means it isn't influenced
by feelings or opinions it's not written
in the first person it's about the text
not me and it's not a judgment or a
review of the information let's be clear
here it's not bad to have opinions
in my opinion it is good to have
opinions but they do not have a place in
summaries you can put opinions to use
when you analyze or evaluate something
when you're looking at summaries and
you're trying to determine whether one
is objective or not look for words that
cast judgment
does the writer say something is good or
terrible or useful or useless
let's do this together i'll take this
text and summarize it without any
opinions
polar bears hunt for seals on thick sea
ice in the arctic as the earth grows
warmer though sea ice gets thinner
with less stable ground some hungry
polar bears search for food inland often
dangerously close to human environments
although polar bears usually keep to
themselves a very scared or angry one
could attack and even eat a human
several villages have set up polar bear
patrols as a result the patrollers zoom
around on snowmobiles using bright
lights and loud noises to scare away
polar bears
hopefully the polar bears find another
snack later on here's my summary climate
change causes polar bears to encroach on
human habitats to search for food as a
consequence these villages have set up
polar bear patrols to frighten them away
as a person who cares about climate
change as well as the well-being of
bears and human beings i have all sorts
of opinions about this but for the
purposes of summarizing that paragraph i
have to put them aside
just the facts ma'am
if you get good enough in making
objective summaries you'll start
noticing when opinion creeps into things
you expect to be objective and it won't
be obvious like bears are terrible and
humans are right to scare them away or
climate change ravages bear habitat
sending defenseless bears into the jaws
of doom human villages but it might be
in the way a story is framed like
there's a difference between bears move
into human habitats and bears are forced
into human habitats what causes them to
move forced by whom or by what sometimes
what's not in a text can be as important
as what's in it
experiment with this a little try
summarizing some news articles and see
if you can restate the facts of the
stories without inserting any opinions
it's a fun challenge and it may expose
an opinion where you didn't expect to
see it
objectively
you can learn anything
dave it out
constant vigilance